a fellow native New Yorker sitting right
here to my right and the star of Cobra
Kai which has been a hit on YouTube
premium to say the least
the reboot television wise and streaming
wise of the great Karate Kid movie which
I cannot believe is 34 years old Cobra
Kai check it out in YouTube premium with
Ralph Macchio good to see you it's 34
years old and I'm only 28 that's amazing
it's amazing you do not look like you
have age today yeah no not really not
true but it's good stuff it's good stuff
considering the alternative I'll take it
right so how often were you asked to try
and revisit Karate a decent amount of
times over the past 30 years you know
whenever I was very protective always of
that character and the franchise and I
just did it was always felt smarter to
to not try to go back to the well and
come up empty then then taint the legacy
of what has become a piece of pop
culture or what has become a piece of
our childhoods you know these you know
Jon Hurwitz Hayden schlossberg and and
Josh he'll the three creators of Cobra
Kai had such a clear vision of coming in
through the Johnny lore in the world of
Johnny Lawrence and whatever happened to
this bully and and and dealing with that
and where LaRussa would be at this time
and they had written a Hot Tub Time
Machine and and and the Harold and Kumar
franchise so they I felt that they
really had a handle on writing for a
younger audience and creating a fresh
world and yet still pay homage to the
nostalgia it was just the right time and
then you have these these services like
a YouTube premium where you could
essentially make a five hour movie and
cut it up into ten half-hour parts and
and again the pilot the first episode
where you're 34 years later running a
car deal at night the Russo Auto button
right and Billy Zabka
right is showing up it's kind of
down-on-his-luck right in a way has been
seen almost 40 million times yeah it's
insane it's wonderful it's it's uh
you know we always felt that this the
these characters and this franchise had
that sort of the ability for that kind
of embrace but to see everyone tell
their friends you have to see this you
have to see this and and then they get
the critics as well it's really doesn't
happen very often and it's it really
tastes sweeter the older you get when
you see something like this happen oh
it's awesome we had Elisabeth Shue on
the show a few you know months ago and
she just remembered being there and just
how you were just young kids on a movie
right kind of not knowing what you were
we had heard of just having like a great
time yeah while doing it
yeah no idea no I I mean I did I didn't
know this I did feel that my there was
such an ease with working with pat
morita that I did feel when I was making
the film that we had something special
something unique there was um you know
it just felt like the two right guys in
those roles it was just I guess it was
because it felt easy to do I assumed it
was coming off well as far as whether
you know wax on wax off and sweep the
leg would be a part of the American
lexicon is it all right you know and now
more than ever so it's really quite
wonderful Ralph Macchio here on the Rich
Eisen show before you get into more of
your pop culture history and and great
TV and movie roles that you've been part
of let's talk a little bit of sports
you're from New your from the New York
City area yep and so you're from Long
Island Long Island Long Island yes Oh aw
and that's right Island that's where
you're from yep so it's interesting
because we were discussing this
backstage a little bit that you're
you're partial to the Long Island based
teams right from your use yes still I'm
like me you know from Staten Island I'm
I'm a Yankee but I I mixed in the Jets
just because I needed a little bit of
yeah I'm a big fan Jets Mets Islanders
are my my team's so I've suffered but
also had some great great great memories
and hopefully looking for some new ones
that's right I mean yeah well listen
when I was a kid I they won four
straight Stanley Cups they with a you
know 80 to 84 the best team
that's a franchise record that probably
will not be duplicated but just by the
way it's set up now
so so we just got Lula Murillo coming on
I was director of hockey operations he's
had pretty good run so it'll be
hopefully he could sign John Tavares and
a couple other things grab a couple
defenseman and goalie and we'll be back
in there you go so who was your guy
growing up bossy receive my seams way up
there Trottier was my it was my guy he
there was just something about him that
I loved watching him play that whole
team was exciting I can't believe the
Rangers put him behind them on the bench
yeah I know that was a rough one for me
to handle just yeah cuz you know I was I
was a berry back kid grow very back
shoot the puck damn shoot that damn pond
that's right and then he wouldn't but
I'm telling you I know I'm predating you
he would be out there on the point yeah
and he wouldn't shoot no shoot the book
berry shoot the button that was what
they were shooting in the Coliseum at or
1940 but that changed the reverse of it
from the blue seats as they used to is
you know the old dump it would always be
pods and sucks that's yep I was always
poppin sucks they still do it to this
day any Ranger on the game elio Potvin
sucks in Potvin well we say he always
thought they were saying Poppins cups
you know and I Rangers have a great one
though the Coliseum is where I saw my
first ever concert too my dad drove me
out to Long Island with all my friends
and you saw Chicago 25 or 6 to 4 well no
it's done base 20 you know and obviously
Saturday in the park but this was also
when peach cetera is a segment doing a
little bit of Karate Kid 2 that's right
you know he's a man who will fight for
somebody's on walk through
when I walk through airports I get the
SportsCenter theme hummed at me from
even though it has been 15 years my last
SportsCenter by the way that today might
be the anniversary well my last ever
SportsCenter I might actually really
yeah might actually be it but what do
you get when you walk around God
what are you good oh yeah I get a lot of
sweep the legs I get a lot of Stay Gold
Ponyboy and get a lot of did you shoot
the clerk okay so the iPad I pepper in a
few and do you really know karate which
is enough to make it look like I know
karate I mean look it's it's moviemaking
or whatever but I imagine you did take
some form of a lesson or yes I'd say
I've taken a handful of lessons I'm
still doing this tougher now than it was
uh a lot easier back then but we don't
we don't bounce back as quick no I know
I'm more stretching going on these days
and then my cousin Vinnie is an all-time
great what was it like on the set with
Pesci hey it was great that was that was
one I call that movie the late for
dinner movie cuz have a phone it's on
its remote you're gonna be late doesn't
matter just can't do it is it is like
that it was that was a funny on the page
and even funnier on the screen great to
be a part of that great ensemble cast
obviously Marisa was launched into the
stratosphere and won the Oscar for that
and Joe just came off of Goodfellas I
just want the Oscar I know so Pesci and
I'm yeah you know I still have signed
cans of tuna for people that's kind of
the funny thing I always liked it
because people do bring me cans of tuna
and they say will you sign I shot the
clerk or the two youths or something
like that it's it's also of course man
that's I mean you sign up for that too
to say no I won't do that not sign tuna
I don't know I don't know I think I've
seen a couple of inbox frames but you
know I guess they're always looking for
something besides an eight-by-ten glossy
and so a can of tuna
probably stays pretty good I know a
couple more
here with Ralph Macchio again check out
a YouTube premiums Cobra Kai right now
streaming there's already been picked up
for a second season which I do want to
talk about before moving on from my
cousin Vinnie because and in our show
history we've been and where this
October could be on for four years the
first ever Super Bowl guest for us
coming off of the deflategate game
between the Patriots and the Colts this
is this is a true fact that will never
be taken away from the Sun on Oahu is
ever going to take away for us and the
history of our Super Bowl shows our
first guest was Marisa Tomei Wow who we
tracked down and said we had to speak to
her because Bill Belichick in his post
right AFC championship press conference
prior to getting on a plane the Super
Bowl dropped a Mona Lisa video never
forget that first of all I got to see I
got to get that tape of a Marissa on the
show it was it was she couldn't be nicer
week already called in it was the first
guest like she could only do it like
literally two minutes after we go on the
air were here and she did she know of
the Mona Lisa veto job she had to she
said that her phone exploded I was
driving I was driving on Long Island and
and I was listening to this and then
when just just hearing Mona Lisa not the
Mona Lisa veto of I almost drove off the
road justly and I looked around to see
if I could share this with anybody like
and everybody was just going about their
business no one had and I just I had a
stop and it was I was just dying to say
did you hear that it just felt so out of
character and everything I just I want
to know the genital never give it to you
because he's a man of few words I would
imagine what was the genesis of coming
up with that was it thought through you
know it's like a great great sports
announcer when they I don't know who was
when I heard the it's pandemonium in
Piscataway remember that that was we
learned years later that was
preconceived short so was was this
something Belichick pulled out of his
back pocket or was he coached if I am
literally if I'd ever do nice if I ever
do have a moment with him I
we'll ask him on behalf of you and
that's it and I want and you got it you
got a heavy basic something that he's
seen over and over and over again as
soon pulled out of his or was he just
you know remote dropped like as you said
it's a remote drop movie was he was eat
just the night before it's positive
Thanks stuff exactly I know that's units
and it's interesting we once I think try
to bring it up to Pesci at a golf
tournament and he was I think already a
couple of fingers into his drink
martinis pulled out at pocketknife right
he didn't pull it on it he pulled out of
pocket nut not because of that but just
cuz he's Joe Frick you guys does what
everyone he does what everyone so the
future of Cobra Kai is bright correct
yes what can you tell fans who have
already visited YouTube premium about
what where this might head well it's
isn't just talking the other day I mean
it's early early discussions of where
the story is gonna go the great thing is
that you know everything is on the table
every character who might have been in
the original film there's there could be
places to go there's nothing set the
nostalgia the way they pepper in the
nostalgia has really worked so well and
we're looking to continue to do that but
also you know keep original fresh
stories along the way that that tie in
both that with something current I think
it's open for business we'll see we'll
see what happens I have no no specifics
as except for the fact that martin cove
is now gonna be a series regular in
season two so everything else from there
we shall see but it's really exciting
you know what Martin Cove was Chris
Wright you know Martin Cove know he was
the chief a whole of the film Oh Chrissy
sensei Chris yeah Chris yeah well look
you didn't watch Cagney & Lacey either
how about that for a poll yeah yeah
about that for a finger on the pulse the
only guy can talk cup final NBA final
and dry
pack Agni and Lacey right here I don't
know these things just Clank in my head
they exist Ralph I don't know why they
exist so are you saying that other stars
of The Karate Kid film may have been
reached out to but should have their
head on a swivel I think some are
campaigning but but you listen with it's
nice to for the writers to have such
that that pool to go to I mean what they
you know also some of the great stuff
that they were able to do is pull
footage from Sony which the Columbia
Pictures made the Karate Kid film just
they were able to pull footage that
didn't appear in the original film and
those flashback scenes are actually cut
in with different shots into the series
of season one and it really changes a
perspective it's really kind of a cool
way to to touch base with yesteryear yet
yet move forward with a story with the
story going forward okay that that's
phenomenal it's great so just Chris
Brockman I know we like to tweet out
fake news headlines and make it seem
real ok whatever guy Ralph Macchio says
Hilary Swank
is campaign any in season two of Cobra
Kai got it well the Hillary's here's the
problem with that one Hilary Swank
wasn't necessarily in a Karate Kid film
that I had anything to do that might
achieve that could be what happened with
that was for wasn't it I don't know what
it was I only I talked about - you sound
like one of those coaches I'm only
talking about them yeah I'm only here to
talk about the players who are here and
it all works it's all good Congrats man
thank you so much grace that's me it's
an it's a great piece of nostalgia and
obviously the reason why it works is
because it's a great story
it's an unbreakable story and it's a
great piece of nostalgia it makes me
feel it's nice and it touches on grey
areas where the Karate Kid films
so good over evil black and white where
Cobra Kai is really your allegiance
episode the episode changes and that
makes it richer you know it shows more
flaws and both things that water feel to
you yes yes because it was a fresh angle
and added more depth and complexities to
adulthood as opposed to you know
Miyagi's team good Cobra Kai bad yeah so
I think that's part of what's working so
well on this tweet or what what is it
can I hit Send on this tweet no I don't
do it all right Ralph wasn't even in the
movie you'll come up with a better one
just say just say yeah just we'll come
up with a better one just rag on LeBron
everybody's doing that's the thing to do
very easy it's open season oh by the way
last the poll question of Ralph Macchio
here before we before you send him on
his way and then the TV audience should
stick around for one more segment short
clip which sequel are you most tired of
anything Star Wars Warriors Cavs in the
NBA Finals or Patriots in the Super Bowl
Cavs Warriors four in a row Patriots
have made three of the last four and
soullow we think Star Wars I think
there's a bubble the basketball the cabs
and they're signatories yeah cuz I mean
it that's how best would set up these
three teams how many teams are there and
then you're you know listen I'm watching
the Knicks and the nets so you know it's
it's kind of tough well now you know how
I felt as a ranger fan watching the
armed that's right we have an hour drive
for five as it was known back in the day
good to see you Ralph you too thanks
Ralph Macchio here stay right there
Ralph and for those of you watching on
audience we'll show you a clip of
YouTube premiums Cobra Kai that's when
we come back here on this edition of the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience